are you a good girl
you're a dirty little girl
who's in charge here what the hell do
you want at my crime scene we're the fbi
i'm with the state police
give me a shout i'm supposed to be
protecting these girls it's not your
operation
you belong to me you understand what i'm
saying
now lift up that skirt no
the minute i got made bait it became my
operation
i have communication with over a dozen
active offenders
we had a bonafide serial killer
i kind of think i'm looking for you
i got a girl with a skull cracked in six
places
the bite marks it matches me
another girl vanished from a truck stop
outside pensacola last night
stop it there who's that
get up it's purification
time
who was he tried to cuff one of my girls
he had a lightning bolt on his truck
he's hurting some girl right now
i can set him up again
you sure do look familiar
not never forget such a pretty face
cheers
[Music]
where is she
folks now you live alone i just want to
keep an eye out for you
you're gonna get me killed we'll have a
little party
don't you worry we'll have our time
together
you